que fue clave elegir a elisabeth born
mujer y tecnócrata como primera ministra
es una decisión altamente simbólica por
tema en el mapa primero porque se trata
de una mujer y efectivamente de los años
90 francia que dan muchas lecciones
sobre todos los temas pues no tenía
elección quedará en este capítulo porque
no había tenido una nunca una mujer
ministra sino durante un año en los años
90 y nunca ha tenido presenta mujer 2
porque es una mujer que viene también
del partido socialista entonces aquí en
el marco no está haciendo también un
guiño hacia el partido socialista para
para obtener su respaldo y tres porque
ha sido una mujer que también ha
trabajado en el tema de la transición
ecológica que manuel bajo ha designado
como el gran tema de su nuevo mandato en
la presencia de francia bueno jenny pero
el líder de la izquierdista francia
insumisa de jean-luc mala visión rechazó
este nombramiento y dijo que el maltrato
social continuará el mismo había dicho
que aspiraba a ser primer ministro si la
izquierda obtenía mayoría en las
legislativas que serán en junio y por
tradición eso es lo que se hace en el
país que en este caso podríamos cronos a
carbón de la cartera y nombrar por
ejemplo melón
eso es lo que se debe hacer digamos en
la tradición el presente stv de respetar
los resultados de las elecciones
legislativas y efectivamente si la
consumes que es este bloque de izquierda
que se llama la nube es ahora su nueva
coalición para estas elecciones
legislativas llegan a ganar la mayoría
en el legislativo entonces emanuel
marcón tendrá la obligación digamos de
nombrar un nuevo ministro que será en
este caso el líder de la coalición que
ganaría la mayoría en este caso podría
ser lo mismo él sabe que es poco
probable sin embargo se ha declarado
como el opositor número uno del gobierno
es el líder de la oposición entonces
pues obviamente a 632 y no podían no
reaccionar al nombramiento de esta
primera ministra en este panorama que
usted nos está mostrando pues hay muchas
cosas en juego de cara junio y por eso
le quiero preguntar cómo deja este
nombramiento al gobierno pues de cara a
las legislativas que podemos esperar por
ejemplo del resto de nombramientos del
gabinete de la renovación
bueno y dice a bilbao no es la encargada
como primera ministra de nombrar su
propio gobierno podemos pensar que es un
gobierno seguramente diferente en el
cual habrá más variedad más
presencia es un tema que le interesa
bastante esta ministra que las mujeres
sean encargos de poder
pero este gobierno tendrá muchas tareas
bien difíciles en primer lugar tendrá
que entonces garantizar el poder
adquisitivo de los franceses que es el
primer tema de preocupación de la
sociedad francesa en segundo lugar
tramitar la reforma de las pensiones que
no será fácil si no cuenta la mayoría
del parlamento y en tercer lugar
asegurar esta famosa transición
ecológica que manuel manjón ha prometido
para ser segundo mandato